voici une pièce de théâtre sans théâtre
ce décor n'est autre que le chaleureux
salon d'un couple de montigny le
bretonneux le temps d'une soirée les
habitants ont accueilli chez eux les
comédiens de la troupe vu sur scène
j'aime jouer chez les gens parce que
c'est une pièce qui est assez intimiste
et donc le décor se prête tout à fait au
thème de la pièce qui est une réflexion
du couple sur son devenir
les comédiens denis tison et catherine
germain incarnent un couple de
sexagénaires au bord de l'ennui
alors que leurs enfants viennent de
quitter le nid familial les laissant
seuls en face à face
t'es pas content aujourd'hui si j'ai
envie de passer à autre chose
j'ai peur de m'ennuyer ça commençait à
s'ennuyer
[Musique]
quand on joue le public est à trois
mètres c'est à dire qu'on le sent on
sent sa respiration sa charge de la
conception du théâtre classique m'a
complètement huit clos dans un salon
cette pièce intitulée bleu caramel se
prête bien à ce genre d'expérimentations
mais ne vous y trompez pas il y a bien
mis en scène on utilise mieux tel qu'il
est idéalement on se dirait à ça serait
bien que la cuisine et soit donc ce
qu'on appelle au jardin au théâtre à
dire sur la gauche de l'image si elle
est à droite ça on fera avec la droite
et donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont un
petit temps de répète sur place pour
reprendre leurs marques
ce soir là les fonds ont été reversés à
l'association l'accord des franciliennes
dont s'occupe catherine je trouve que
c'est vraiment une idée à développer à
ça fait passer un bon moment ensemble
c'est ça sort un petit peu beaucoup même
de l'ordinaire à la fin de la pièce les
comédiens accepte volontiers de partager
un moment de convivialité
alors n'hésitez plus la troupe se
produit dans toute la france